Bộ lợi vụ dự báo, quy một năm 2018, số người có việc làm tăng khoảng 8,000 gàn,
sau với quy mốn năm 2019, nước tổ số lâu đầu có việc làm lên khoảng năm 2018,
và nạn đà phục hồi và mở dựa sản xuất ngày từ đầu năm.
Bộ lợi vụ cho biết, độc lực tăng trường chủ yếu đến từ hút vực sản xuất chế biến.
Trong đó, ngày sản xuất chế biến thức phẩm, dự kiến tăng ba về một phân chăm,
sản xuất vương tịn vật tài tăng hai về sáo phân chăm, sản xuất xay có độc cơ tăng một về sáo phân chăm.
Ngược lại, một số lĩnh vực như sản xuất thuốc lá, sản xuất hoa chất và sản phẩm hoa chất,
sự chữ bảo dưỡng lắp đặt máy móc và thiết bị có su hướng sản việc làm.
Báo cáo tình gình tết quyền đảnh đến gọi hai nghìn không trong hai mì sáo cho thấy,
giá đoạn giá tế xuất hiện dịch chuyển lâu động đánh hạn,
thiếu lâu động sau tế mạng tính chục kì.
Bộ đá theo dõi sát tình hình, đồn đốc kết nối cùng cầu, bảo đảm nhất lực cho sản xuất,
giết là tại các khu công nghiệp ở hạn nội, bắt ninh, tháng nguyên, thành phố hội chỉ mình đồng này.
Dự kiến tỷ lệ lâu động trở lại làm việc, đặt tảm 15.000, từ hai ba đến hai 15.2 và chỉ 15.000 vào tình cuối tháng 2, hành hình không trong hai mì sáo.